you
hi my name is Luke Siciliano I'm a web
developer I'm also a self-employed I've
done a video before for freako
camp on the topic of whether or not you
should go to freelance or
self-employment route after you're done
learning how to code we're going to link
to that video in the description below
now assuming that you've decided hey I
think I want to be a freelancer I think
I must start my own company I think I
want to work for myself
rock on good for you I think you should
go for it I think you're gonna find the
experience incredibly rewarding both
financially and personally with that
being said there are a lot of things
that come along with running your own
business that can cause a lot of people
to feel intimidated and that's the due
to the fact that when you're working for
yourself you have to deal with a lot of
things that in the past an employer
handled for you things such as how do I
deal with health insurance vendors
because when you've got a job you just
sign up for the plan the employer gives
you well now you've got to figure out
where to get health insurance from
things such as how do I pick our
provider for my retirement account
because again when you're employed your
employer just you know says here's what
we go through you're going to go through
Vanguard fidelity whatever and you just
sign up for their plan of the things you
have to start dealing with when you're
self-employed perhaps the issue that
intimidates entrepreneurs more than
anything else is the topic of taxes you
know people might be concerned about how
much am I going to be taxed on how do I
pay my taxes during the course of the
year how do I get my a the government so
on so forth I am here to tell you that
the issue of taxes which we're going to
break down on all this in a second is
not something that you need to be
intimidated over and you certainly don't
let it need need to let it intimidate
you to the point that you decide not to
start your own company okay you've just
learned how to code you can learn how to
deal with these kinds of issues so just
understand working for yourself means
continuous learning you're going to
learn how to deal with issues and you're
going to be successful all right so do
not let these kinds of issues especially
taxes intimidate you out of working for
yourself so in this video what I'm going
to do is talk about three things number
one I'm going to talk about what it is
you actually are responsible to pay
taxes on what what's your income when
you're self-employed I'm going to talk
about how you can structure your
business to manage your tax obligations
provide some kind of basics that we do
in our business you know to help
streamline some of these issues one
thing I'm gonna really stress before I
get into this is the fact that I am NOT
a licensed tax professional I am NOT
holding myself out as one I am NOT
holding myself as any kind of a
financial adviser these are things you
really need to talk to a lawyer about
talk to a tax accountant about so on and
so forth to figure out what's best for
your particular situation what I'm doing
in this video is sharing my knowledge
with you and explaining to you what wait
what we do in our business so with that
being said let's look at what it is you
actually pay taxes on in other words
what's your income when you're
self-employed a lot of people make the
mistake of thinking that everything that
comes into the business is their income
so in other words person one rights you
would check to build a website person to
write you a page of cash I should say to
build an app person number three you
know get paid on a credit card to build
some local software that they want to
run all those things come into your
business that is not your income that's
your revenue everything that comes into
the business that anyone pays you is
what's called your revenue so your
revenue is everything that comes in you
have expenses which are everything you
pay out to run the business maybe you
had to pay write a check to Amazon Web
Services maybe you had to rent an office
maybe you had to pay the utilities at
that office that's the money you spent
to make money so everything that comes
in is your revenue minus everything that
goes out is your expenses and after that
you get what's called your net income
okay so under our little scenario here
let's say during the course of a year
you brought in one hundred twenty
thousand dollars in revenue ten thousand
dollars a month get building websites
building apps whatever during the course
of the year your business paid out
twenty thousand dollars you had to rent
an office you paid Amazon Web Services
you know you had to pay utilities at the
office you know things of that nature so
you brought a 120,000 in revenue you
paid out twenty thousand eight and
expenses that leaves you net income of
$100,000 so at the end of the year when
you're reporting your income to the IRS
this is the number you report as income
one hundred thousand dollars and this is
the amount that you will be taxed on so
depending how you structure things a
certain percentage of this is what
you're gonna pay to the government you
are not going to pay a percentage of
revenue you're gonna pay a percentage of
your net income generally speaking okay
now how much of this one hundred
thousand dollars you pay to the
government and how you pay it to the
government during the course of the year
will depend on how you structure your
business so now let's take a look at
three ways that you can structure your
business there's a lot more than this
but for the purpose of this video I'm
gonna go over the three that if I had to
guess or the most common for real
answers small entrepreneurs things of
that nature
one is a sole proprietorship I've got
sole P for that one is an LLC which is a
limited liability company and the third
is to choose to tax yourself as an S
corporation or an S Corp I'm going to
talk about each of these in turn
sole proprietorship means you don't go
out and start a separate business in
other words you're doing this as an
individual you don't go out and start an
entity you don't go start a company you
know so in other words instead of
starting an LLC or an S corporation I
just go out and get a business license
and I start building websites and doing
these things for people individually and
then they write a check you know
directly to me and then that all goes
into my revenue so that's the sole
proprietorship it's not a separate
entity you know you're just handling
things directly and at the end of the
year you're if you're a sole proprietor
you're going to attach what's called a
Schedule C to your tax return and that
Schedule C will report your income or
your revenue your expenses and the
$100,000 in income and what this person
will want to do since they're not
getting a paycheck they're self-employed
is every quarter they're gonna send some
money in to the IRS and then that's
going to be the same as having or in
lieu of
should say having a withholdings from a
paycheck and in you make those estimated
quarterly tax payments to make sure at
the end of the year you don't get hit
with a huge tax obligation because of
the fact that you have income from that
so sole proprietor again just to be a
little repetitive not a separate entity
just an individual essentially an
individual for business license money
comes into the business or I should say
into them personally every quarter they
sent an estimated tax payment into the
IRS at the end of the year they report
their income under Schedule C on their
personal tax return if their estimated
tax payments cover their obligations and
they don't know anything else if they
overpaid their tax obligations they'll
get a bit a little bit of a refund if
they underpaid they have to write the
IRS a check that's how the sole
proprietor works
another option is an LLC this is stands
for limited liability company as opposed
to a sole proprietorship this is an
actual separate entity you have started
a separate entity a separate business
and what happens is the LLC you start
the LLC the LLC gets a business license
all this revenue comes into the LLC in a
bank account in the LLC's name all these
expenses get paid out of the bank
account that's in the LLC's name at the
end of the day the money that's left
over gets distributed to the owners the
owners write themselves a check they
call it a distribution and that's how
they get their money from the business
the LLC does not pay any taxes okay at
the end of the year the owners gonna get
what's called a k1 it's a tax form the
owners gonna get a k1 from the LLC
saying LLC at 120 thousand a revenue LLC
had 20 thousand in expenses LLC profits
are 100 thousand dollars the individual
owner will pay taxes on the 100 thousand
dollars on their personal tax return
same as with a sole proprietorship if
you're going the LLC route what you want
to do is send in quarterly tax payments
to the IRS so at the end of the year you
don't just have to write a huge check
for your taxes and it also helps you
avoid getting hit with any penalties
so that's an LLC the third thing you can
do is choose to be taxed as an S corp
this is what we've done in our business
no an S corp is another form of a
company but what we've done is we have
started an LLC and there's a form we can
you can file the IRS link to in the
comment form below where you are telling
the IRS that we have an LLC for tax
purposes please consider us an S corp so
in other words for all legal purposes
were an LLC but as far as the IRS is
concerned we're an S corporation an S
corporation works a little different do
you remember with these I was talking
about how you just distribute money to
yourself as the owner well with an S
corp if you're owning the business
you're also an employee of the business
so you set up payroll just as you would
for any employee you're required to pay
yourself what's called a reasonable
salary and in you any profits on top of
the salary you distribute to yourself so
in other words let's say you know after
expenses company brings in a hundred
thousand dollars let's say an average
reasonable salary for a web developer in
my areas sixty thousand so you know I've
run payroll just like I would with any
other employee and I pay myself a salary
of sixty thousand dollars because I'm
required to pay a reasonable salary to
myself taxes get withheld out of my
paycheck just like they would for any
other employee and then after that sixty
thousand dollar salary I've got forty
thousand dollars in profits left over
because 100 minus sixty is 40 I take
that forty thousand dollars as a
distribution so just like here and here
total I'm getting a hundred thousand
dollars it's just that here you got
distributed a hundred thousand dollars
directly here you got distributed a
hundred thousand dollars directly here
you got sixty thousand dollars in salary
and a $40,000 distribution now again
this is what we do in our business and I
know hearing what I just said this
probably sounds way more complicated
than these so you're probably wondering
why would you want to
own the business and be an employee of
the business and deal with payroll and
give yourself more headings okay and I
understand why people feel that way
here's why you do that when you get a
paycheck from an employer you are used
to federal income tax being held out
you also see Social Security Medicare
Medicaid FICA those kinds of things
being held out of there let's call those
things employment taxes Social Security
Medicare Medicaid those are employment
taxes well when you work for yourself
because you're not getting a paycheck no
one's withholding anything from your
paycheck so I talked about with these
you're going to send estimated quarterly
payments to the IRS but those estimated
quarterly payments only apply to your
federal income taxes they don't apply to
Social Security Medicare Medicaid FICA
employment taxes which is what we're
calling them so at the end of the year
you're going to have to pay what's
called a self-employment tax on top of
your federal income tax and your
self-employment tax is the equivalent of
those employment taxes Social Security
Medicare Medicaid so on so forth so sole
proprietor and an LLC if you make a
hundred thousand dollars on top of your
federal income tax you're going to pay
employment tax or self-employment tax on
the hundred thousand dollars which is
about 6.2 percent so in other words
after these people have paid their
federal income taxes they're going to
pay another 6.2 percent or in this case
six thousand two hundred dollars to the
government on top of their federal
income taxes to make up for the fact
that they didn't pay in the Social
Security Medicare Medicaid during the
year they're gonna pay self-employment
tax
so that's sixty two hundred bucks on a
hundred thousand dollars now let's go
down to my scenario again that I gave
down here excuse me remember I said
you're an employee of the business and
you also own the business well when
you're an employee and you get a
paycheck that means federal income tax
gets held out our Social Security
Medicare Medicaid gets held out
so that Social Security Medicare
Medicaid is 6.2 percent the same as the
employment tax that these people pay so
on that sixty thousand dollar salary
again we said you're getting a sixty
thousand dollar salary of $40,000
distribution out of the hundred on that
sixty thousand dollar salary you'll pay
the 6.2 percent employment tax the thing
about an S corp is that that forty
thousand dollar distribution that we got
on top of our sixty thousand dollar
salary you pay federal income tax on the
forty thousand dollars but that forty
thousand dollar distribution in other
words anything beyond your salary is not
subject to the self-employment tax so in
other words you do not pay the 6.2
percent of self-employment tax on that
forty percent profit okay where $40,000
I should say profit which under our
hypothetical right here would say if you
call it twenty five hundred bucks
six point two percent of about forty
thousand dollar profit profit is roughly
twenty five hundred dollars so in other
words the sole proprietor pays six point
two percent employment tax on their
entire hundred thousand plus federal
income tax on one hundred thousand the
LLC pays six point two percent
employment tax and federal income tax on
a hundred thousand the S corp owner pays
federal income tax on the four hundred
thousand because they took sixty
thousand salary and they've got forty
thousand profit they pay which is a
hundred thousand they pay federal income
tax on all that but they only pay the
employment tax on the salary portion and
the profit does not get hit with that
six point two percent tax so if you were
to add up all the obligations at the end
of the day this person's going to pay a
little bit less in taxes than these
people so there are some tax advantages
to doing an S corp which is why you're
going to go through the extra rigmarole
that I talked about a minute ago of
setting yourself up as an employee so on
and so forth now
a couple of things about this is you
have to pay yourself a reasonable salary
you know you know you can't pay yourself
five bucks or something like that you
have to pay yourself a reasonable salary
talk to an accountant talk to your CPA
about what is a reasonable salary for
you to be paying yourself
that's issue number one issue number two
is that there's some complications that
come along with an S corp in the sense
that yes you know you have to pay
yourself a salary and manage all that
that don't make that complicated sign up
for a payroll service to manage that for
you we use intuit payroll services in
our business there's a lot of different
payroll services like ADP and whatnot
they will if you sign up for your full
service options they will manage the
withholdings for you they will like file
your different state and local forms for
you so on so forth so you're not buried
and paperwork all the time so while
setting yourself up as an employee may
sound complicated using a service a
payroll service to manage that for you
actually makes it pretty simple I mean
again we use Intuit merchant services I
would say at the end of the day it's
actually pretty seamless having
ourselves set up as employees of the
company and we save money in taxes at
the end of the year you know because of
it so again what we do in our business
is an LLC with an S corp election that's
what we do in our business but what's
best for your particular situation is
something that you need to talk to a
lawyer or an accountant about one last
thing I want to close on with this is
the topic of your expenses one mistake I
see a lot of entrepreneurs making is
they run the risk of underreporting
their expenses there are a lot of things
that are expenses for your business that
you might not realize if you leave your
office to drive to a business meeting
your mileage might be an expense if you
go out to a business dinner with other
developers and for work purposes it's
possible that the cost of the meal might
be
business expense there are lots of
things if you have to buy a computer for
the office that might be a business
expense there are lots of things that
businesses that our business expenses
that people say hey I'm not sure if this
is an expense or not well at the end of
the year what those people do is they
might have a stack of things that
they're not sure if their expenses so
they don't give them to the accountant
well if the accountant doesn't know
about those expenditures they're
certainly never going to be counted as
expenses on your tax return right so
what I would suggest doing is save
everything you've got to document your
expenses is you know you can't just save
my expenses or X you have to have
documentation of them save all your
receipts document everything or on the
side when you're talking about your
expenses or on the side of saying
something is an expense and at the end
of the year give everything to your
accountant and have your accountant tell
you whether or not something is an
expense don't make the mistake of
thinking I'll just assume this is not an
expense assume it might be an ask your
accountant okay because you want to
capture all those expenses that you
possibly can because again if your
revenue is 120 and your expenses are 20
you pay taxes on or $100,000 well let's
say under this scenario there were
$10,000 and things up in potential
expenses that you missed and you didn't
give you it to your accountant so that
means you brought in 120 the only
expense 10 so you pay taxes on 110
thousand dollars in other words your tax
bill is bigger record everything give it
to your accountant and let your
accountant tell you whether or not
something is an expense I'm not saying
to just put everything on your tax
return as an expense I'm saying ask your
accountant about it that's the one last
piece of advice I will give now we all
know there was a big tax change recently
and that the tax code is different for
2018 prior to doing this video I have
talked to the CPA that does our taxes
and he has in
you know what he told me and again this
is not advice to you and all what he
told me is that this is still the way to
go he is advising us to continue to go
this way that I've just talked about
before our taxes even after the change
in the recent changes I should say in
the tax code so if you have any
questions feel free to contact me
directly I know this may sound like a
lot trust me taxes are not something
that should intimidate you out of
running your business okay
they're just not get a good CPA talk to
a lawyer structure your business the
right way so you pay as little as tax as
necessary make sure you record all your
expenses and hey you'll be fine this is
what we have CPAs and lawyers and stuff
for right so again if you have any
questions contact me directly and good
luck in all your endeavors
you